[Musik]
jetzt haben sie mal den bohrer hier
ausgepackt
löw ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen hier zu einem
weiteren reha video auf einem kanal und
zwar ich wollte einfach ein real live
video aufnehmen und diese verdammten
scheiß nachbarn die bohren einfach den
ganzen tag ich weiß nicht gibt ihnen
recht was irgendein gesetz das die nur
zu bestimmten uhrzeiten bohren dürfen
weil die machen das von morgens 8 uhr
bis abends 22 uhr
ich kann ja nicht mal richtig aufnehmen
ich habe mir einfach gedacht bevor heute
nur sondern so ein kleines app video
kommt dachte ich mir ich mal noch ein
ganzes klitzekleine trier live-video
weil mich ganz damals mal viele gefragt
hatten wie das eigentlich aussieht mit
mein iphone hüllen weil ich irgendwie
voll vielen realer videos immer
unterschiedliche iphone hüllen habe
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich nehme
mal ein paar aus bielefeld von zu hause
hier mit nach hamburg und stellt euch
einfach mal so ein paar vor
ich habe sogar zwei zu hause noch
vergessen aber ich habe trotzdem jetzt
glaube ich gerade sieben stück habe ich
dabei die ich mir vorstellen kann uns
jeder so eine kleine hintergrundstory
sagen kann und wir fangen erst mal an
mit der die ich beim iphone 5 hatte und
zwar war das hier meine allererste
iphone hülle
das ist einfach eine von cellular leihen
oder so keine ahnung will er mal hier an
fokussieren das ist einfach nur so einen
bumper ähnliches macht schwarzes ding
also das ist einfach nix das ist denke
ich so was hatte jeder irgendwie schon
mal als iphone hülle das ist leider als
handy höhe zumindest das ist einfach so
da sind auch so überall so ganz da sieht
man richtig dass das richtig oft
hingefallen dass ich hoffe mal der
fokussiert das ganze jetzt jemand an das
sieht man nicht so richtig aber an den
kanten sind halt so richtig diesen
teilweise richtig abgeschliffen dass mir
das richtig oft hingefallen ist das
handy aber das ist auf jeden fall meine
allererste iphone 5 hüllen oder so die
ich hatte das ist einfach nur sonne
sonne matt schwarzer bumper ähnliches
teilhaber ist gar nicht gerade so bin
ich jetzt mit ich hallo bin ich mit ich
hier sind ruhig danke so jetzt zu meiner
zweiten hülle die ich will mein iphone 5
damals hatte das war wirklich ein
originaler apple bumper aber da an
diesem beispiel könnt ihr euch mal sehen
dass nicht alles was apple produziert
qualitativ hochwertig ist weil deswegen
hatte ich glaube ich jetzt ein halbes
jahr um
und das ist bei sonnen teil aber dies
auseinandergebrochen
die reist auch hier oben schon
auseinander wenn wir das mal hier so ein
bisschen das ist die strecke ist ein
bisschen auf das fokussiert immer so
richtig geil und guck mal hier die ist
so aus glas überall schmutz dies und
auseinandergerissen
ich hatte die wirklich damals mit am
strand im urlaub und so und ist in sand
gefallen und die kann es echt nahe
zwischen auseinanderreißen und was weiß
ich alles also das ist meine zweite oder
das war so neongrüne das ist einfach so
und grüner bumper also ich denke jeder
hat schon mal die zeit wo man auch so
krasse farben gestanden hat sowieso ein
grelles orange oder so und grün oder so
ein ganz helles blau oder irgendwie so
und das war so eine zeit wo ich dann
auch so t shirt hatte die einfach so
komplett orange waren und so und das war
der pampa zu der zeit und der ist
einfach kumpel hätte macher steht dir
mal ne ich nutze hier sachen echt bis
sie irgendwie das ist aber echt eine
eigenschaft von - alles ist irgendwie
auseinanderfällt auch bevor ich mir
irgendwas neues kaufe erstmal das also
noch komplett ausland meine
fußballschuhe damals hatte ich so lange
bis die sohle auseinandergebrochen sein
die nächste hülle die ich hatte erinnert
mich immer noch so ein bisschen an diese
hätte ich euch gerade vorgestellt hatte
diese macht schwarz haben schwächer
gezeigt uns war es das einfach so eine
von apple allerdings aus leder und ihr
seht schon die ist total verstaubt weil
die hier ist überall staub an weil ich
dir damals beim iphone 5 hat nun die
wahrheit recht qualitativ richtig
hochwertig weil ich hatte die glaube ich
richtig lange drum und die hat das
hätten die einfach komplett geschützt
also dies wirklich glaube ich aus leder
sogar meine ich ja dann halt auch
irgendwie 40 euro kostet also ich habe
allgemein so viel fucking geld in diese
blöden iphone hüllen der halo euro
wie sehen mich an hallo
siehst du mich ja ich habe so viel geld
in diese blöden höhe nicht mehr
investiert aber dies auf jeden fall
richtig geil gewesen
[Musik]
freunde das ist nicht witzig was wir
nebenan machen wollen wir wollen einfach
das komplette fucking haus renovieren
und den interessiert ist ein scheißdreck
das ja auch noch leute wohnen und
schlafen wollen oder irgendwie so sind
war ich hab gewarnt also das ist die
dritte hülle hier einfach von von apple
sondern so eine lederhülle würde ich mir
auch definitiv noch mal holen aber ich
glaube das iphone wechselt die nicht so
gut aus und ich habe zur zeit von 6 wir
kommen gleich zwei von sechs sollen
allerdings habe ich hier noch drei
hüllen für das iphone 5 danach habe ich
mir dann so eine band hülle gekauft da
die war damals mich dabei als ich mir
meine fans gekauft hatte ich habe
irgendwie 34 verschiedene bands und die
war dann irgendwie damals dabei dass die
sieht so ein bisschen ja die hat dieses
plans muster so sehen halt events schuhe
dieses profil von unten aus da steht
auch hier eine seite fans dran und so
wenn ihr das malerisch herein die ist
auch sehr sehr geil gewesen nur die
wahrheit dann so ein bisschen sperrig
und da dachte ich mir näher kommen auch
nicht so geil hatte ich wirklich nicht
so lange drum also die sieht ist auch
gar nicht benutzt oder so die ist nicht
dreckig oder irgendwie sowas also die
hatte ich echt nicht so lange drum weil
auch vor allem diese farbkombination aus
weiß und rosa es ist glaube ich er sogar
den frauen hülle oder irgendwie so war
halt dabei von daher habe ich die auch
dann habe ich mir gedacht hab ich bin so
witzig ich hole mir so eine
taschenrechner höhle für mein iphone 5
und das ging natürlich nicht also da
konnte ich mir jetzt keinen
taschenrechner benutzen oder so aber was
mir aufgefallen ist hier die zahlen das
ist gerade zwei spiegelverkehrt glaube
ich aber wenn man das ganze umdrehten
steht da helau also ist jetzt auch
spiegelverkehrt aber das war so ein
kleiner insider jetzt voll spät
aufgefallen dass man mit den zahlen 0 77
34 halt zum heller machen kann
jetzt haben sie aber den bohrer hier
ausgepackt also keine ahnung da war ich
halt so der hochphase ich hole mir
taschenrechner hülle und deswegen würde
ich sogar zweimal mathe unterricht
angesprochen dass wir wir haben das
teilweise so mathe gemacht damals
wir haben aufgaben gerechnet wo man
teilweise den taschenrechner nicht
benutzen sollte weil man das haben wir
so gelernt wie man große zahl
miteinander multipliziert und ich hatte
mein handy hat auf dem tisch liegen
diese hätte das kind anstrich
also das ist meine hülle nummer fünf und
die hülle nummer sechs die letzte iphone
500 ich euch heute vorstellen ist die
aller geilste finde ich eigentlich uns
war hatte ich die aus dem legoland oder
irgendwie so mitgenommen oder aus dem
phantasialand oder aus irgendeinem
freizeitparks das ist einfach so eine
iphone 5 lego hülle oder so und man kann
wirklich hier oben drauf so lego figuren
drauf setzen und so die ist eigentlich
genau so wie diese fans finde ich glaube
sogar dass ist von denen von den von
belgien ja das ist beide sogar von
belkin meine ich warte ja ich hoffe ich
kann das mal die kamera zeigen kommen da
da sehen wir dass belgien belkin von
beiden also die sind beide von der
gleichen vom gleichen hersteller
ich finde allerdings diese lego hülle
die tat dann nachher zeit wirklich wie
in der tasche weil diese steinchen die
sind so ein bisschen die kellner
servieren auf einen legostein ausersehen
draufgetreten seit sie klein war da hat
man dann schon mal zehn jahre lang
geheult
ja jetzt ist meine hülle nach da unten
im moment ist wieder da wo freunde ich
muss den echt jetzt mal irgendwie gleich
mal was sagen dass dich hier die ganze
zeit am pakt und vorhand sind das ist
auf jeden fall meine sechste und letzte
iphone 5 hüllen dann gewesen das ist
einfach diese lego hülle aber die
nachhallzeit echt mega wehgetan in arosa
und das sind dann auch schon mal eine
iphone 5 hüllen gericht ignoriert ist
jetzt bitte einfach wenn ihr neben an
borden keine ahnung wie lange ich das
noch machen wann sie endlich fertig sie
mit ihrer scheiß aufgabe da aber ist er
jedenfalls sind dass sie meine 56 66
iphone 5 hüllen und
keiner habe ich zu hause vergisst das
war so eine ganz normale iphone sexuelle
wurde so hinten so karte reinstecken
contest nur die habe ich dann zu hause
gelassen weil mir gesagt wurde von unter
anderem sturm waffel und ein paar
anderen freunden noch so ja du musst du
aufpassen wegen bewegen dem kult und so
als wegen diesen gegen diesen
magnetstreifen von ec karte oder so das
kann durch die funkwellen des iphones
beschädigt werden ja ich mir gedacht im
internet stand zwar dass das ganze
keinen einfluss darauf hat aber warum
sollen wir das risiko eingehen wenn man
sich muss deswegen hab ich die hülle
nicht mehr benutzen haben jetzt eine von
fit irgendwie geholt oder so heißt es
glaube ich das ist so eine stoffhülle
die nervt mich aber mittlerweile auch
schon und zwar ihr wisst das glaube ich
ich seitdem ich jetzt euch hier die beim
iphone 5 vorgestellt habe ich mag iphone
hüllen deswegen werde ich mir demnächst
wieder eine neue holen das ist so eine
von mod 3 heißt das glaube ich dass es
eine die bord man so dran und dann ist
das einfach nur so nix hinten drauf und
ich glaube mit der werde ich dann auch
endlich mal zufrieden sein und mir dann
nicht wieder jede woche neue iphone
hülle kaufen müssen ich weiß nicht ob
ich bin also ein mensch der gerne mal
verschiedene dinge ausprobiert denn
gerne variabel ist also nicht warum aber
ich bin sehr gerne flexibel was so
sachen angeht wie dass ich teilweise mal
das aussetzen kann teilweise mal die
hülle nehmen kann teilweise man den
rucksack nehmen kann teilweise man die
weil das blabla ich habe da immer sonnen
sondern sondern etwas anderen geschmack
teilweise von tag zu tag
ich hoffe trotzdem euch hat das video
gefallen das soll jetzt wirklich kein
großes geheimnis video hier sein sondern
ich hatte halt nur damals mal gesehen
das ende kommt da an stand wie viele
iphone hüllen hast du denn eigentlich
stellen wir uns doch mal vor und so und
deswegen dachte jetzt einfach so ein
zweites video hier heute noch am tag
sein kurzes glaube ist es sogar mehr als
sieben minuten jetzt sogar lang könnt
ihr euch eventuell gefallen wenn ihr
lust habt könnt jetzt bewerten wenn
nicht lass es einfach und ich werde
jetzt auf jeden fall noch nebenan gehen
und denen ordentlich die bude da
einheizen und